hey guys it's justine and today we are
unboxing the brand new dji mavic 3 in
this mysterious box that has no photos
or labels or names because the version
that i'm testing out is currently not
out yet so this is very exciting to open
up this secret mystery to show to you
guys of course by the time you see this
you'll obviously know what it is so at
the time of filming this it's a secret
shh so there's going to be two versions
of the mavic 3 so there's going to be
the regular version and then there's the
cine version which will allow you to
record directly to the drone with a one
terabyte solid state drive and you'll be
able to record prores 422. the other
thing to note is these will now fly for
about 46
minutes it's kind of crazy to think
about where we started from with dji
drones and drones in general battery
life was such a crucial part of it and
the fact that we can now get all of this
technology inside of this drone and be
able to fly for about 46 minutes i'm
excited oh this looks like it's got like
a nice little
case
whoa look at you
[Music]
this is a big case this is like
this is
this is nice
hello this is a nice fabric
what the heck look at you this has got
like these nice little clips on the side
this is premium
what's in here
there's all kinds of secret little
compartments
oh my god
oh my
this
hold the hold the roll
this turns into
a backpack
what in the world what kind of
magician nonsense is this
oh and this even has
this little zip right here so you can
put this
onto like your luggage i'm already
impressed with the bag i haven't even
got to the drone yet
oh whoa
look
at
this what the heck this is so
this looks like something out of star
wars like this looks like darth vader
like if he had a pet this would be his
pet it's got this cool little
interlocking system to keep the blades
all in place for travel
okay we've got a couple more boxes here
just gonna take out everything look at
this incredible
bag i'm so impressed with this bag i
can't get over it
looks like we have a new battery design
all right
that is everything out of
this incredible
modular bag what a great idea wow
whoever designed this
freaking give them a raise let them know
that they did a great job and i
appreciate them and if you
are a part of that team that worked on
the bag i need you to send this to your
boss and be like justine says we need a
raise and if they're not going to give
you a raise at least
demand
they buy you dinner pizza something
anything give them a gift give them a
trophy send me their address i'll send
you a trophy oh look at this new little
charger i like this a lot it has the
built-in
adapter just like so usbc
this is freaking nice i feel like dji is
killing it recently with all of
their new innovations keep up the good
work
[Music]
what
the heck why does this look so good
look at this it's like got a little
it's like a little belt like a little
suspenders like little overalls this
thing
looks vicious look at this beast mavic 3
you have
really outdone yourself
oh my goodness
this has two cameras on it
look at this okay this has a dual camera
system this is
wild so the four thirds sensor is the
hasselblad camera which can shoot up to
5.1 k but then you have the telephoto
lens which can shoot 7x optical
28x with digital and 4k
30.
holy moly i'm
not even sure
how to process this but i'm currently
processing it and i cannot wait to take
this thing outside and fly
[Music]
also have a few other accessories here
in this box
oh my gosh
we've got
some extra props just in case you never
know
additional cables depending upon what
type of phone you have we've got the
micro usb and the usbc additional usb-c
cable for charging
and the multi-battery charging dock and
here's what the new batteries look like
i feel like these are kind of closer to
what the fpv drone batteries look like
love that they have a nice little
docking station
oh
look at this
i almost threw this away there's nd
filters don't forget about those these
are crucial to your droning experience i
wonder what these look like because we
have the dual cameras like look at that
freaking color me impressed i forgot i
can't wait to go outside
the one thing that i wish that they
would have done with this controller i
actually really do like this newer
controller design but man they really
had a missed opportunity to match these
dark grays it's okay no fault just you
know maybe for the future
like a darker gray version
awesome wow all right
time to charge
and let's get out there
[Music]
so we're out here for the first flight i
cannot wait there's a lot of surfers and
i know that surfers don't really like
drones so i'm gonna try to stay away
from them but the morning is perfect i
love it i'm so hyped and this thing just
looks like a beast like look at this is
vicious
it's so cool this one does come with
some nd filters this whole piece will
come off and i'll be able to pop on a
new filter here's the little filters
like look at this cute little case
that's six four thirty two eight we're
gonna do 32.
and you go
oh man after all the first flight is
always so exciting but also terrifying
oh my god it's so pretty out
this makes me want to go out on a drone
adventure so bad
[Music]
the fog is rolling in over the mountains
oh shoot
the best thing about this is the flight
time we've got about like 46 minutes
like that's just absurd
[Music]
so now i'm going to test out the c4k
we're going to be shooting also at 24
frames a second
let's
take off
[Music]
i think i'm going to switch actually
into the explore mode this is going to
go back into 4k but i want to test that
zoom oh my goodness okay this is crazy
this is wild
[Music]
i get so nervous like flying through
things even though i know i have so much
room what's in there
oh there's all sorts of trash
[Music]
gps signal week i don't like that
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so crazy because i have not been
concerned with battery life at all i
mean right now i'm at 30 and i'm like
i guess i'll come back but i don't have
to like i haven't been worried about it
sling's a beast i'm so excited let's go
to a new location
[Music]
so
we just went and filmed at a second
location and this time we decided to
shoot in the pro settings so when we
filmed this morning for sunrise we were
just shooting on auto wanted to see how
everything worked watched that playback
and then made some changes this time we
switched up the nd filter to an nd8 and
then we also alternated between the 32
just to see how they would play changed
a bunch of settings and i'm so happy
with the footage like everything looks
incredible i've been having so much fun
with this drone but the one thing that i
will say at launch some of the features
aren't actually readily available which
honestly like i'm upset about but i
would rather them hold off on launching
these features and then they're terrible
and everyone's complaining like this
doesn't work something has failed why
did you guys launch this well they
launched it because you were complaining
about it not being there and then it
wasn't ready so the fact that they are
holding back on it i feel like actually
says a lot so i'm just double checking
some of the features that aren't going
to be available at launch but they will
be available in january 2022 the
hyperlapse master shots the focus track
including spotlight active track 5.0
point of interest quick shots panorama
quick transfer and 4g transmission
that's a lot of features that aren't
ready but honestly
shooting with this thing
i was very impressed with the footage we
ended up just shooting at the best
possible quality shot in d-log and
it's pretty awesome the one thing that i
am excited to see i know some of my
friends have the cine version of this is
being able to shoot in pro res and
having an internal one terabyte solid
state drive inside of your drone
recording internally pretty freaking
awesome so the city package does come
with some additional nd filters but for
what we were shooting going all the way
up to 32 seemed to be perfect also the
battery life on this thing when you're
flying a drone you don't want to be like
up in the air for literally two minutes
and by the time you get to get your good
shot and then you gotta come back again
i didn't even think about battery life
it never even gave me an alert by the
time i got all the incredible shots that
i wanted to get i was like i'm bored i
filmed everything that i needed to film
and i brought it back i did get one
notification that said that the
wind conditions were really really windy
and i ignored it and continued to fly
and never once did i actually noticed
that it was windy at all this thing kept
stable it was flying like a champion and
even just flying felt so smooth i've
also been used to flying the dji fpv
drone so i've been very used to flying
just super fast erratically and
wild so it's kind of fun to go back to
sort of a cinematic drone and get some
really fun slow shots and really kind of
focus on getting something that looks
cool two freaking lenses on this okay
let's just can we just go back to that
it was very
shocking because when i was flying with
this thing zoomed in i was like i don't
even know how to explain it it was such
a weird feeling because it felt like i
was so close to things and i was afraid
to even fly but then i would zoom all
the way back out and realize that i was
absolutely nowhere near the thing that i
was filming was kind of cool you can go
all the way up to 28x zoom and some of
that is digital so you are going to be
seeing some quality loss but what's so
cool is you're able to kind of just go
and see is that somewhere that i want to
go are there any obstacles and then you
could actually fly the drone there and
get that crisp shot but the telephoto is
actually pretty impressive the fact that
you're able to get these crisp shots
when you're really nowhere near what
you're trying to film it's pretty cool
so this is really just a first look at
this drone since a lot of the features
aren't really ready but a lot of those
features i have used in previous drones
and i'm really excited to test them out
in this one this is definitely the
higher end as far as prices are
concerned so the mavic 3 which is the
basic package is 21.99 and then if you
want to get the fly more combo with
extra batteries that's 29.99 and the
mavic 3 cine premium package is 49.99
and i'm honestly pretty excited about
this drone just because it is so light
and being able to shoot in 5.1 k
i'm so used to shooting at such a lower
quality with my drones because i usually
prefer a smaller drone to take with me
but this like i this is still a small
drone and i'm not gonna have to
sacrifice the quality so thank you guys
for watching i look forward to testing
out these features when they finally
launch so if there's anything that you
would like to see me test out please
leave it in the comments below and i
will see you guys in my next video as
always if you haven't subscribed click
that subscribe button hit the bell so
you'll be notified when i post a new
video and i think that girl over there
needs to subscribe
i'm gonna go ask her she's into drones
[Music]
you